nous sommes dans une situation
inextricable
mais le sort pour quelques présidents de
ce soir vous avez vu si monsieur macron
comme tout semble l'indiquer succède à
dunkerque je trouve que cela crée un
acteur et ça vient par nora illi l'inde
autant lui vous êtes vous le verrez
jamais rien ne manque ici d'aller le
voir hier soir à poissy je suis resté
trois heures j'ai vu passer de lire des
films de journalistes qui auraient mdi
je pense que j'aurais été un chien je
pense que j'aurais plus attirer
l'attention
mais il a peur d'abord il a toujours eu
peur des gens savent et il n'est pas à
l'aise il y faut des salles bien
paraître comme les maires et commencer à
poissy
regarder des images de prix c'était des
petites questions bien gentillette c'est
pas du tout des questions à la mélenchon
vous voyez ce que je veux dire mais il a
peur de lui et ça ça ne guérit pas nos
mois il a un problème de calage entre
ces niveaux de tension internationaux et
la réalité d'une campagne or comment les
français n'ont qu'un homme a perdu toute
notion politique et ils vont bien
vouloir avoir un minimum ne sans débat
sur le paysage ils vont réélire moi je
vous dis cette affaire n'est pas
terminée parce que c'est macron lui-même
qui est le plus dangereux adversaire
pour bertrand
mais ça veut dire que l'élection de
malfrats n'est pas du tout remise parce
que moi je sais pas comment il va tenir
cette campagne pendant quinze jours ça
va les changer d'avis il ya quelques
semaines vous disiez que toute façon ces
macro qu'il gagnerait la fin non mais
parce qu'on a écourté ma footing boutade
non non c'est pas une totale c'était
voleurs phase deux qui m'ont dit
qu'elles savent aux premières mesures
jeudi à peut-être première mesure
puisque c'est makoun qui veut gagner à
faire gagner compte tenu de la toute la
finance qui l'a au derrière il a tout la
finance quand vous voulez vous faire si
je n'arrive pas et si nous n'arrivons
pas à faire comprendre cela par les
français et au vu du chant saison côté
iavoloha qui nous a fait le cadeau de
zemmour voyez
[Musique]